[Music]
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
to those who are in the room and to
those who are waiting watching us
remotely today we have a final intern
project founder some of your who is in
student in ok Institut National de la
recherche scientifique in Canada under
the supervision of dr. Thiago Falk and
today he is going to talk about his
intern project audio quality assessment
with deep neural networks without
further ado Anderson you okay well for
this nice introduction thank you all of
you for watching my presentation this is
the outline of my presentation start
with a little introduction on audio
quality assessment then we dedicate some
time to explain our data set which took
a massive amount of time to develop and
it's really nice data set then we
discuss our proposed approach for the
plan of audio quality assessment and
then the results in the conclusion so
what is the audio quality assessment so
the idea of the audio quality assessment
is to estimate the quality of the audio
based not just on the signal attributes
such as SNR noise level speech level or
manipulative deliberation but also
considering the human human factor and
human subjectivities so at the end we
want a model that can give us a number
that we represent the quality and why
this is important so many multimedia
services network systems they need to be
monitored and we cannot just look at the
quality of the services without
considering or taking into consideration
and the user the end user what we could
do was to have a feedback from the end
user to monitor service but this is not
always happen so an alternative is to
have a model that can tell us how good
is our service also considering the
perspective perspective of the user so
at the end we don't want to in a for
example
voice call and avoid the user having
problems of not hearing each other or
not being able to synchronize the
conversation so all these things can be
monitored and improved if you have a
feedback from the user so these are some
of the possible exhibits of network
environments the Qing hinder a a call
war can compromise the quality of the
audio so latency jitter pact loss in on
the signal sign you can have like speech
distortions such as additive noise
reverberation clipping so all these kind
of artifacts can hinder communication
based on audio so how we can actually
assess the quality of the auditor we
have two alternatives one of them is to
have people assessing the audio files so
we can have a speech being recorded and
people can listen to it and then each
participant can give a score then you
get a quick Scott MOS the variance is
just the mean or the average of all the
scores and this is important because it
eliminates the subjective needs of each
individual so each person has their own
reference of quality it depends on many
different aspects for example the
person's an expert they might be more
weeded if the co or the the audio the
contents is important my awesome finish
the score so with the MOS we can
eliminate these factors so the
subjective nee subjective listening test
is actually the most reliable one but it
has some drawbacks so it's time
consuming it's laborious it's expensive
and I think one of the things that is
really complicated that it cannot be
done in real-time so you have a model
that can do this for you you can
actually evaluate your systems on the
fly so another another tentative to
so the active listening task is to
complete mos using an algorithm so we
replace the human by a computer based
algorithm we have two types of
algorithms can be signal based so the
algorithm looks at the signal and
extract some attributes or parameter of
the signal to estimate the quality and
have a parametric base which is use
network parameters to estimate the
quality and we can have a hybrid one so
we can use the signal without reference
right cos media quality or we can use a
double-ended one which is the reference
so have the degraded signal the Queen
the King signal and then you compare the
two that's what Basque does we're going
to talk about this match in a little bit
so these are some of the mostly non
metrics are measures for audio quality
assessment we have passed a new version
with can be used for wide band signals
polka so these are all developed by the
itu-t organization and you can see that
14 task is more restrained for codecs
and compressions not really for noise
and reverberation other kind of
impairments that you can have in the
signal so you actually have some
limitations so therefore this is
actually the motivation for our project
so although Basque is widely used it has
some drawback it was not really trained
for distortions introduced by this
speech our trained for distortion
introduced in this speech is compression
but it is intrusive so it needs the
clean speech or a reference speech to to
compute the output so our objective is
to have new oven
that can be trained on noise variation
audio popular distortions and also that
is not intrusive so there these are the
two main things that we are looking for
when you look at the literature review
we are actually in this project we're
focused more on deep learning approach
to build our model when you look at the
literature review we see that there is a
lot of work on using deep learning for
predicting mostly intelligibility and
but not really for speech quality in
general most of these approaches are
based on a speech recognition
so they actually estimate the quality
considering the performance of the
speech recognition systems they're to
approach that policy this year yeah you
think those are papers that recent
papers they are focused on deep learning
to solve this problem but most of them
focus on intelligibility and ingenuity
that intelligibility such actually just
one factor or one aspect of quality so
this paper I thought was interesting
although it's also focused on
intelligibility but the idea here is to
have a spectrogram of your speech signal
and then use a CNN and their kernels as
a filter to estimate the DMOS
it actually eliminates some of the
engineering features that we know by
using silliness of as a flute a NASA
Canyon this one was also a paper dr. was
interesting is a and indeed waned no
intrusive speech quality the assessment
model and it uses a spectrogram and a
LST m2 is made the quality so I thought
was interesting that they built actually
their own cost function we customized it
and
together
the correlation between each samples or
the sequence of samples here they
estimate the quality by frame so usually
what we have is the overall quality for
the whole who trains and in this paper
they actually were able to exploit this
information to estimate the quality of
by frame and then get the overall pollen
no talking about the data data
generation so we had it's been a
particle time to try to generate more
disk data set with different impairments
we had initially a clean speech 2000
files then week involved it with
different inputs response to simulate
reverberation distant talk we had
development speech samples then added
noise who had like four four categories
of noise and with different SNR and also
different speech levels and my selves
we're going to show all the statistics
on the data in fewest lines so at the
end we had like 10,000 noise samples and
to train our model we divided this way
so I want to now talk a little bit about
how we labeled the data before yeah it
should be 10 10 degrees
okay so this is just a model how the
quality is perceived by the humans they
actually are divided in three events the
first event is the physical event is the
waveform reaching out the ears we
perceive the the sound then we have the
perceptual event where we actually
extract the features such as loudness
noise knees reverberation so we
automatically extract those information
from the audio and compare with the
desired features so the desired feature
is the internal reference that each one
each person has and then we can make a
judgement so after doing the judgement
we have were able to estimate the
quality ourselves and then maybe have a
description of what effect was played a
role on this mission of quality so
basically this is what will happen
when we have people rating our our
speech fire our samples oh this is the
yeah this is the perception it's a
judgement this is the description so
have the perception of the physical
event which the waveforms we measure the
features internally so that's the
perception event we compared them with
the desired feature which is which is
your internal reference then you can
make a judgement how good is the call so
the thing is that people have different
desired features right so have different
expectations and then we do the the
description so the idea of the mos is to
minimize or mitigate this this
I live here is the so here's like
considering the desired features with
reference and here is just considering
the degraded signal so the here to be
like ain't no intrusive and here each of
you because you have so I thought it was
important to before talking about our
listening test or listening quality test
to make clear what are the effects that
people are listening to so we have like
the variable in speech with Archie sixth
ranging from 300 milliseconds to 500
milliseconds and in our discussion was
the most common range in had close talk
in anechoic speech so in terms of SNR
this is our basically the range of snr
we're gonna check the distribution of
SNR in a few slides so we have also
noise in speech level varying so these
all these variables actually are being
assessed by people well those are the
rt6 that we we had at hand I think one
of the things that we discussed this
these are the most common type of srt-6
dead-looking finding rooms like such an
office or in house so you be higher than
these I mean there's some like a treated
office will be 200 my living room is so
why not go from
yeah I think this you go from zero to 40
DB just curious because this is the
impossible sweetie have you guys gave us
I also had like the Skype pipeline which
he apply enhancement to this all these
interments and actually we divided the
data set between 50 percent with using
the sky pipelining 50 percent not using
it and we see like there's an
improvement
it's like improvement using the sky
pipeline
it's the ECG yeah and also the humanity
so actually this is what yeah so when
you do the EDC what is output of this I
mean this they're like us so not just
what happened well when we look at the
distribution of the mos at least you see
a slight improvement this is not huge
but it's actually doing something in
terms of enhancing very slowly so if you
don't do the ADC I would assume the
signal would saturate in some some of
these sounds would saturate and the MAS
will suffer because of that I mean what
is the reason of doing the ADC why do
you need that to analyze the performance
of voice of freshmen and ADC the whole
with language compaction we need age you
see because somebody can be optimal
meters and be decanted 4 meters this is
4 times difference in the level of you
the speech signal you need you
equalizer before to send it to the other
party that's the first thing we did not
do normalization when you will compute
the error message the entire affair
Avenger multiply it simply because
agency introduces its own distortion so
the gain goes up and down based on what
he thinks when we have speech emotive
who we wanted those distortions to be
implanted into the signal so to get the
users to judge how much EBT is
discernible and did that affect him us
they wondered like he says there was
some change in the mass link how did
this from time to time actually it's
annoying but in most of the cases is it
serious
so it is he had a big impact it wasn't a
gist it was an improvement but noise
suppression was because I didn't feel
nice so in general agency with the voice
activity detector who explains quite
well if the way the VD misfires and we
have a noise signal and consider it the
server starts to run the Westlaw and
that's does not sound well or if
somebody speaks for a far away in the
video does not fire then it's that the
voice still states weak and this also is
not very pleasant but in the realistic
case the edges is still there like in
the real case when people are really
using this use process you to the
skyPoint cap the code which is imperfect
I think yes
okay so that's this is what coming to
the participants
so for each condition we had ten
participants so we averaged over ten and
then get the subjective scores so you
know we don't not just getting the
scores but we also asked the
participants to evaluate each one of
these effects then we're going to see
how it they relate to my eyes
they're actually they are always on so
you have like mixed effects here you
know I have like exclusive effects so
this is actually the which is which is
the outsourced company that provides
human resource for us to do this kind of
experiment so people the first thing
that they do they read the guideline
they go through a training where they
get familiarized with each one up for
the impairments noise reverberation etc
then they go to a qualification part
where they go through the experiment and
then we use a gold standard file so we
know what expect from from their ratings
so after that they go through they go to
the test itself so they listen to the
file after that these buttons are
enabled so they can rate from one to
five and then we asked them which device
they are using and also which
environment was mostly disturbing this
is a little bit of the did exploratory
analysis this is our MOS and this is a
task and this is Darren are what we des
and I are supposed to be a like a normal
so we actually added a little bit more
low SNR so we get the MOS to shift a
little bit to the lower values and the
reason is because we want our model to
actually learn how to rate also this
kind of situation but people were kind
of generous when they were rating what I
was thinking like because people are not
using our service they were like working
for us so they tend to be I think is
that make play effect so we have to
derive it because remember we need to
averaged over 10 people or even more to
eliminate the subjective individual oh
but the way I see that pesky is he
markedly more close to the SNR in
submission you look at only at the
signal basket doesn't really look at the
subjectiveness of the supposed to do
crane I don't think he was trained for
this trappers if stea told me to avoid
the distortions posted big speech
compression that was the initial idea
behind so you have codecs with different
between different cortical context
almonds which means predominately
relatively clean signal from a forum or
closed book microphone you compress it
and then you compress it and if you have
to judge the quality so this is why even
the traces of noise make best to give
you a low score because these thinks
that the does the codec introduces those
huge noises there I don't know anyone
because we have plotted best can poker
remember like you know that experiment
they were quite reasonably correlated so
you see risk and most from the judges
have 0.7 correlation their correlation
you see the same trend it just there are
outcomes absolute value Pesky's okay
mostly and gives lower score when you
see noise when this voice is natural
humans are more forgiving can we use
this for our speech enhancement yes
valuation choice I tell mr. Chaplin of
white bisque is bad but we don't have
anything better than that
so this is the penalty yeah just this
point about demos I think if you people
were using our service they would be
more restricted with demos I think the
fact that they are kind of getting paid
to do this they might be more generous
that's one assumption
No okay so a little bit tomorrow more
about the data so here we have MOS in
SNR and you see that
so MOS tends to be correlated it to SNR
not saying that it's the cost for the
SNR but it plays some some effect
listener so the noise level it seems
like when the noise level gets higher
people tends to give a lower mos but
it's still like lower is still like
three right which is that's why I get
the shift MOS distribution for me the
way I see this is people are more
concerned with the speech they really
can hear it so if the noise is tolerable
they don't they don't really really care
much yeah so ya know this is this is
actually the MOS is the Mercy's already
what is that line in what are those dots
the line is like the correlation between
the two
how did they vary together correlation
doesn't mean yeah yeah of course like I
mean just to have an idea so it's not
here is not the just the s turn arteries
that's why I showed the this slide here
so people know that these things are on
all the time so you cannot really just
analyze SNR and say that's don't know so
each dot should be a file right
each dots should be a Fire's that's
right and so each filed its rated 10
times 10 and then the curve should just
be the mean of that Oh what is that what
is it being around the curve that should
be a confidence
but time to the Sun in general noise
level per se is not indicative because
under the same noise level if you have a
long vowel or softer speech signal you
would get different results s tonight is
more indicative in you see that it is
actually yeah more yeah but I was
curious to see how these two things
plays out considering you know because
these things I changed it together
we don't have fixed speech or annoy so
these are all effects on the outcome
where's that noise level and speech
level yeah I think the fact that you see
you actually see a chord like of course
there are interactions but you cannot
deny that there is a correlation it in
general again so so the speech level in
doesn't mean any more than the noise
level but the fact that they're
delivered at the same absolute playback
level it shows that okay if you crank up
the noise it doesn't really matter as
long as the speech their voice yeah it's
okay yeah that's good but I don't see
that in a third feature
I was unexpected third pitch would be
the same or similar to the middle no
because imagine you have noise here but
you don't really care right because you
are being able to understand or listen
so that's why as the speech level
increases my ass is increased so you can
have a better level of speech so it's
it's more comfortable for the deletion
I think you saw that Sunderland right
and I think one of your comments was
that that's why you were saying that
let's let's lower the speech level
that's what people are getting bother me
yeah to get to lower mo yeah I'm just
concerned about that this distribution
here the dart Center booted all the way
it looks like but yeah a lot of her eye
ability because you know they have other
things going on here it's not you cannot
just say oh this is noise in my eyes no
yep that's why it's difficult to
estimate it says there's a lot of
interaction here you have all these
things playing you can't have problems
in the networks properly simulated with
a lot of dopant packages what is the
jump will not even occurred this is come
true these are those of the files I know
what people have animated them and we've
computed the mean right so Daniel seems
to be a nice little body
they say the MAS is let's say you have a
foul at 20 DB SNR but this file they can
be disclosed as from the speech
enhancement distortions from the agency
they simulated Skepta simulated the
network they may be packages dropping in
certain files which brings the quality
down so I think the bottom line clear is
that they are way more factors impacting
the perception of the quality than the
essence I will just move quite
frequently use it in scientific papers
as the quality measure
yeah I mean the point of me here is just
to say there is some trend in the data
and we can actually expect some
information but we cannot say like this
is causality which means pas pitch 11
and here this is also I think
interesting so this is actually what
people reported as more disturbing so
and then actually when they report the
noise was more disturbing noise was
actually increasing in terms of
disturbance we have a decrease in mos so
that's what people thought
so before was the the ground truth right
and here with reverb so as we're all
said maybe we should have there's a
trend here but this the acts this noise
but this is what people said if we have
three judges of 10 clicking content is
noise in the file you'll get to 0.3 this
test is here because each judgement
there is a noise in the file is
resolution of 110 because you have ten
judges three click communities 0.3 noise
level
this isn't this the wrong way to plot it
because x-axis should be the only thing
waiting everything else should be the
same what every point yet to understand
the trend if you want to study the trend
between math and drugs in the silence
rate but this is kind of more practical
think you have 10,000 oh sweet I
understand by Nationals of everything in
there I understand but this is I mean
you cannot even put the same noise and
moist
but still still you can say that when
pretty much everybody hears the noise in
the file
this means you lost one and a half
points applause oh there are the factors
at play just not just that's fine you
try to basically eliminate them by
averaging this is the train line yeah I
think the problem I think we can do that
kind of exploration you just wouldn't
have more need more time get the data
yeah but we don't have that in our data
that's the thing the way our data was
generated we have mixed effects in the
data that's what people are hearing we
can what we can do is when plotting it
we can
we get the SNR with one range and then
get the other but the SNR is random so
if even within that range we're gonna
have some nice but that's the thing we
don't have that because people have the
option to - that's you see this is not
moot it's not exclusive so you can hear
noise and because that's what is in the
file
noise reverberation have mixed effects
that's possible because you have people
totally no interest affirmative manner
and then steam was the door wasn't open
active from highest impact or the most
so we still have to do some datum and
also I guess the question you're asking
here is for people to tell you what you
already know
you put the noise in that you put the
reverb in there you're just asking
people how well are you able to
correlate your own judgement to what the
condition was but in the end you
probably don't care about whether people
thought that was too much really care
whether right or not because because
then I think this that factually
unnatural speech cuts most the
perception of the quality you see you
can you can lose up to two points for
unnatural
there were piece less data points yes at
some point more and more people pick on
the report but they don't furnish that
much and noise is somewhere in between
which might just be an indication that
we were might matter but it's not
something people think about money
people Oh score maybe and that's again
that there is a ground truth you know
how much reverb there was so you can
actually
or maybe just just listening for humans
forever he did a thousand times 5
million 20 seconds he's here this is
okay this is true yes which is pretty
much a normal environment so they don't
get much annoyed by that distortion okay
so now let's go to the proposed approach
the first approach that we thought was
using a vector so the vector has been
widely used for recognition tasks so
that was one of the motivation so having
has been used for speaker vilification
language recognition emotion recognition
and the question was all about speech
quality so can can you use a vector for
that and I vectors they are known to
carry speaker and also channel
variability and the way you can think
about the vector is you extract several
reservations from your speech file
usually
MFC sees and the bottom line is so you
want to map those features into a
utterance level vector which is the eye
vector so we want to map them in in this
total variability space so the way we do
that is first you compute a gem mu B
model so this background model will have
a bunch of speech files and it's gonna
be like a reference or like a mean in
this space here after computing the JVM
you extract some statistics from each
one of your observations here so you get
what is called a super vector so the
super vector is composed by the
components of your gem and the features
length that you have in your in your
feature extraction so this super vector
here
is what you are going to use to compute
the the DI vector so M here means
independent super vector which comes
from the GMM and you have the dependent
super vector so the dependent super
vector depends on your speech file so
that every new speech file you are going
to compute like the offset from the GMM
would be n which is kind of hard mean
mean high vector to do that you have
also to compute the low-rank total
variability matrix which is a matrix and
we used the u BM and the bomb Welch
statistic to do that so this is the
framework for the vector effort
preparing this framework we extract the
R vector for each utterance in the
training set and deficit and in fact set
so here are some plots of the vector the
projecting the clean speech which is the
dark blue dots here and mos below 0.5 so
we see that it projects the VI vector
and can actually separate the two
datasets so here's considering MOS
between 2 & 3 and when we consider
actually the whole three levels of MOS
with the clean speech we see that the
data get a little bit mixed up there's
some clustering here but if there's some
some limitations so then we thought
maybe you can use AI vectors combined
with a DNN MLP architecture to find a
better representation to compute a
morass so this is the the architecture
that we proposed like we have high
vectors of 400 dimensions have with two
hidden layers 200 hidden units first
layer and the second layer used drop out
for as regularization and we do as an
activation function and then we predict
DMOS
with this model
so the other the second approach was
using what is called the key exceptional
coefficients and again it's has been
used in basically in speaker
verification to detect natural and
natural speech and has been very
successful in that so that was one of
the motivations and the other one is
that it's a psycho psycho Cuzco
motivated so the idea of the constant K
ki sabzi or coefficient is they say that
this Q or the quality factor increases
has the Freak the frequent center
frequency increases so as you go up this
this factor will increase because the
the window name that you extract your
your your samples they are they are
fixed so what they propose is to make
this Q factor constant and change this
so that this doesn't change so the the
motivation for that is that we're going
to get a spectrum there is high has got
better resolution for high frequencies
and in low frequencies so that's how it
would look like so you'd have this kind
of spectrum using their model the c QT
so this is how it is computed so it
could be the spectrum but using the Q
transform the power spectrum the log and
this is actually a spectral features so
they use a they had to change the scale
the log scale and they do that by using
this uniform and then they compute the
disapp so we use two approaches for
these features the first one using side
row and the second one using the
spectrum and so the idea here was okay
so if you remove
the signal process computational of the
spectrum we know that space sexual
features are very well established but
if you let the DNA and look at directly
on the spectrum would you get better
results that was actually the question
here okay so this is our evaluation we
use revolution setup so we use the
Pearson correlation in the mean square
error to compare the models as baseline
we use MOS and we compare also the our
results with SMR we 563 impacts so SR
Mar is also a metric a measure for
estimating reverberation and want to see
if they can also be able to estimate the
quality for the impairments that we had
and P 6 P 563 is another metric is
unknown to diplomatic there is it's it's
right okay the recommendation 560 okay
so all the results are based on the test
set no we try but you get rid of it I
didn't get a grab for it but we didn't
we didn't the didn't have the code for
that
[Laughter]
so maybe next summer okay so this is the
results for the a vector and actually
it's pretty similar to the results we
get with the CNN on the sap so
coefficients using the cue constant and
one thing I was thinking here is that so
a vector is projecting sets of features
or MSE sees to the total variability
space and the CNN is basically doing the
same thing here so that may explain why
the results are very close
so this was a bit surprising for me so
actually like removing one signal
process computation we get better
results just looking at the spectrum and
and then have passed to compare with the
SMR and P 563 we also explored with the
help of David and honey's another
architecture using mail features in a
full connect MLP and gotta play good
results here so the other thing that we
explored was using this same extractor
here which is computing the my asana
utterance level but using all on the
frame level here okay so what we did was
to compute here the we use all the
features here on the frame level as
input for an EMI LM and extract some
static from the OEM to get the result so
what we found is that the eom actually
helps to decrease the variability of the
data from 22 because in this case so you
get you go you have a sigma q new
movement and get those certain number of
variable than this nation silly how we
keep them beautiful in to the LMI know
how it's all spelled out in Yahoo for
the utterance we just take all the
frames over in the utterance and that's
what's has to be its video and that's
also the appearance results how can we
get them know the number for the uterus
here on each what to do correlation
this is no he's telling you get a
coalition for frame I think just like on
the same frame so you have this network
a running on a segment of 25 frames and
then next next next legs right and you
have a bunch of numbers which is not
variable in how you compute the number
for parameter us here was the result
never
we just looked at all the frames that
were in endurance there are 25 frames I
mean 25 actual hospital segment by
segment there so so each of those what
we called the 1450 vector frame each of
those frames we just looked at the core
of the what what was the result you know
what was the last estimation on that and
we just looked at the correlation over
all across all those frames all Eichner
level before the LM and then the other
half of the year so pretty much busy
small solution this just tells us how
much how much they are not rosy okay and
but those are and everything's utter
it's based off clubs so that's also my
darks based so pretty much the last line
museums come down to our core network
sorry MSE is computed between what -
okay oh yeah did the to the ground truth
which which is demo s and in your
prediction
oh yeah we but we have okay in the test
set you have in my case of 1500 - yeah
so young now is like and they're
estimating by 0.17 basically no this is
just a Pearson correlation no embassy so
the error in estimation is about 0.2
meaning if the best is 2.5 or mass is 2
point 5 this is estimating two point
seven to three point three roughly years
yeah well yeah
so technically ten people with your
average ten people get around 0.32 b
square l square of ten times less so
technically this means that if we get to
0.17 over 0.16 you are as good as 50 ish
people doing this okay so this one is
looking at this extra so you complete
the spectrum and then you complete this
sideshow and then use this n n so this
one is just it just expects from you
that's right yeah
this man
so so we just to conclude we develop a
new audio quality data set with with
labeled and I think it's very realistic
data settings for a lot of things on
this data we explore also the effects of
mixed impairments on MOS we explore
three approach to estimate MOS and we we
show that our methods are performed all
the baseline methods so the next step so
we want to base gate
maybe the combination of vectors with Q
several features see if we can get
better results we definitely need to
test our algorithms in new data sets and
we want to explore more new network
architectures into and DNN so we want to
explore a bit more DN n plus ml and caml
and so I'd like to say a special thank
you for the sky team so Shannon was a
great help for us as well great
discussions I learned a lot in this
internship I'd like to thank you all the
people that supported funded Johannes
and Scott honeys Kemper Dave Johnson so
it helped a lot also with technical your
technical expertise was really nice to
have you guys and the whole all doing
acoustic research group especially van
was really nice for sauce I was there
when I need it and I was a great time
for me
questions it was actually quite nice
discussion during the talk if you have
more questions please ask comment I
think one of the main conference shred
yeah one of the main things to do in
this is actually to do what - for
suggesting right is to get expert
opinion of this because people are given
some raw scores but it might just be
random I know how reliable they are
because these people are just people
right
yeah but isn't that the point though no
you also want to get an expert what is
it what is an expert opinion I play a
sound file that has five different five
different distortions and yeah you can
say based on my expert opinion I think
there's 500 milliseconds reverb that
might actually impair your judgment
because now you're basing your judgement
based on based on what you hear in the
file of what you might perceive when you
have an actual phone call with you that
is but exact is going to give you metric
to say how much is the variance around
basically if the ten people mark in the
mosque or varies from 0 1 to 5 then it's
just noise wait I mean I was saying you
said it was one point standard deviation
between typically embossed spent math
skills
our parents are 70 Asian is quite right
it's not it's not but he had I don't
know how much was the study I mean I was
right so the Senate deviation is about
five years if I didn't lose this yeah so
I think that comes from these terms over
for this 0.7 okay so the reason I was
suggesting getting experts to check some
of the ratings this looks like you have
a central central bias so things are
kind of centered around three to four
mm-hmm rather than spread out yes a
bunch of experts they shouldn't have
this bias yeah so you know here learning
buildings that are more critical whereas
a ninth grader will tend to rape and you
know the mean of the central tendency by
us I mean f3
yeah I think there are a lot of things
that I think this kind of experience
will never be really realistic we try to
do as much as we can
one thing that I was thinking is is
different when you are listening to an
audio and when you are having a
conversation using Skype service so then
if you are paying the services even
worse but there you are getting paid to
do that so I think that also my selling
data to itu-t and their job is to just
collect data for evaluation and you are
doing it for three months it's a great
achievement thank you we're doing as
much as we can one question how much
cleaning of the data that you do with
any consistency checks that you find bad
Raiders at for all out we didn't
actually did much on that actually do we
have spam filter all right so if some
were being too much time from
the mean
so about standard and that was actually
problems we we stopped getting you mean
like during the test or after I could be
post-test
yeah the post-processing right we didn't
have any time for do post processing but
I mean we did which I had to kind of
write so when you have ten judges and
everybody said we
you still yeah yeah you see then I think
there's a lot of variety in these days
I'm for sure but it'd help if you then
look at each charge of the specialist
given the multiple example high school
example to look at what vectors ranges
in it so what another thing is like the
fuse if you check at the itu-t
recommendation for this test they say
students should start with the
conditions that you want to do this
experiment so the condition will be very
clear people should not have second
guess about what they are hearing but
this is this is not really skews not
going to be in environment with only
reverberation or only noise so that's
what I think was the challenge of this
dataset to have something realistic at
least on it on the side of the
environment maybe one consistency check
that would be you also ask the same
rater given the same file and make sure
they are rating at the same that they're
off by a huge number
once one small comment many on the since
you collected what people used to listen
to the same rules there might be some
interaction between if they listen over
of speakers such as pH level is low then
yeah it's just drowns in your
environmental noise where's the noise
level playing lower I doesn't have much
yeah that's right now Jesse just seeing
my oh I have a date the mining we can do
yeah come with thousands one hundred
thousand channels yeah is that my
neighbors entity just throwing out all
the speed speaker based ones and see
what kind of data there's this company
which does which des polka which
develops all this press and all that
what is the company's names you know
somewhere in acoustics after how optical
and of course it affects control
software but they don't say so you
$30,000 quote that to us and they don't
say optical so you poker no one actually
selves they have to do this yes we both
actually the actual I'm Skype I plan so
whatever they did is very very scalable
questions because you really don't want
to read all these opinions if your
intended application is for telephone
quality Skype in in a conference room
quality versus kind of at home quality
so definitely this is something you I
think honey's were saying right but then
you cannot call it mos anymore it's
called some do you really get valuable
information it's more tailored to your
application
I don't know how because the ITU - they
say should have like 20 people got ten
is enough pretend like you Weiner
experienced like it's kind of see your
deviation of the average is way lower
than humans so technically you only get
better results there are a bunch of
humans and I just estimated 0.16 mean
square error compared to one of a single
human is a colon there at least 0.16 is
equivalent of test with 40 humans is the
number if they winter statistics okay
but that's pretty much means that each
measurement with this tool is equivalent
of most with 40 humans mortgages again
one question to this slide we show the
correlation between as an RN so that was
the correlation between the SNR how you
generated the data yeah this the actual
so it would be just would be interesting
to see the correlation if you compute
the SNR at the output which are serving
contains like tasty impairment of the
processing and all these and artifacts
and average loss and these things into
account
yeah and now we'll probably expect to be
to be there's so much higher correlation
so as not is what the input of the
pipeline no doubt is the intuitive they
put so technically it's actually this is
hair because the sky pipeline could
stain but they think is a voice yeah but
we have like actually 50 percent of the
data is without the pipeline so he
actually could check the difference
at least yeah but in the calm of 20d
Basin are the files with 20 DB input a
sinner and the files with 20 DB input
this is number processes by this time by
a plan which means the output is let's
see
assuming 10 DB SNR improvement they are
actually at the 30 DB where to go yes
Sebastian is right this rule if you
measure it exactly the and that's pretty
straightforward engine it will make the
but still in Sasana is a poor quality
indicator it's the easiest blue kingman
that can actually be added to the list
of estimators just as an hour but the
snr after you have at the output it's
actually hard to compute real time it's
easy to compute here but because we have
the clean speech file within the video
the police are each and then estimated
yeah just just as a reference point for
a camera
comparison what question so you use the
constant ten samples the time ratings
profile but in reality that should
probably be adapted because different
noise levels different parent eyes will
require more ratings or less ratings
some humans are not going to be
consistent across all different types of
files okay you could use your data
figure out which how many samples you
need
okay for dependability impairment that's
right yeah there's a lot of data to play
with for a long time
[Applause]